[Music]
Vandal Savage an evil dictator blessed
with immortality he has achieved what no
one in human history ever has
he has conquered the entire planet and
you are rip hunter I'm from East London
and the future I've been tasked with
assembling an elite team to travel
through time to capture savage before he
grows into the monster he becomes of all
the people who ever lived I chose you
eight I certainly hope that you won't
let me and the world down I can get
behind that it's time to start bro it's
gonna get a little rough
we've lived in the shadows long enough a
hero in the light
let's get this party sure it's a good
idea to leave these two unsupervised on
a time machine we just burn pal
human love almost got us killed if you
two considered couples counseling
I know it's difficulty to fathom of in
the future none of you hear us
your legends course plotted for 1975 all
your worlds are about to change
before excellent waters crap fortunately
we now have larger problems and Savage
it's on universal to me but the dangers
of upsetting the timeline I've seen men
of steel die and dark nights for your
entire 21st century world or some group
has already seen the future he knows
exactly what's in store for each of us
if we have the power to change the world
don't you think we have the power to
change our own fate for better or for
worse I like being part of a team man me
too
let's do this
I love the seventies
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so another
early Christmas present first big
legends of tomorrow trailer with actual
footage from the series so let's break
it down and I'm starting a new round of
the reverse flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video a lot of you did see the trailer
that they posted earlier this year
before the CW up front and we're a
little confused because it's like you
know what's the deal with this footage
Oliver's wearing his old costume isn't
he supposed to have his new costume if
this doesn't pick up till after the
mid-season finale of the flash and arrow
well the footage that they aired earlier
this year wasn't from the actual series
that was just a promo they made to sell
the show to advertisers think of it as
like a proof of concept this trailer
actually has footage from the series in
right away you are correct Vandal Savage
did say Man of Steel and Dark Knight in
this so Superman and Batman do exist in
this universe if anyone's ever asking
but I think they're only able to get
away with it because it's a
tongue-in-cheek reference and I'm not
expecting to see them actually be on
screen but the really big stuff first
rip hunters Timeship it's called the
Waverider it you know has the like the
little WR on the side of it I'm totally
expecting to hear a bigger on the inside
joke we'll see you know I mean because
this is Rory we're talking about but if
you remember to the finale for the flash
season one when a bart thoughts getting
ready to go home in his little time ship
he said it looked like an early version
of rip hunters first time ship if you
have read the time masters comic it's
more of an easter egg for that that's
what rip hunter ship looks like in that
comic book but if you do want to read a
comic book to read about rip hunter time
master things read vanishing point
that's much more recent they go back in
time to try and find Batman but this
season of legends of tomorrow is all
about them stopping Vandal Savage from
taking over the world in the future and
they make it sound like Vandal Savage
also gains some mastery over time
probably not to the degree that rip
hunter has but they make it sound like
Vandal Savage is also messing with the
timeline but the producers basically say
that the reason rip hunter comes back
and assembles this team is because he
sees all these awful things happening
and he wants to clean up the timeline
he's like this should not be happening
so that's the case it might be like the
flash season 1 where like the timeline
has already been changed when the show
picks up like oh my god Vandal Savage
messed the timeline up we have to fix it
now but Marc Guggenheim did confirmed
that they would be visiting very big
points in time very big events in DC
Comics history past pres
and future now because they said that
Vandal Savage has taken over the world I
don't think we're gonna be seeing any
kind of crisis on Infinite Earths but
they could totally do that in a future
season they did say that the idea is
that the caste would rotate a little bit
season to season so they can cycle
characters in they can cycle characters
out and they're only doing I think it's
like 13 to 16 episodes so it's just a
little easier for them to get contracts
with big actors the problem with getting
really big actors is that they're
usually hesitant to sign away their
entire year to a single project so if
you tell them oh you only have to do 13
episodes so you still have time to go to
a movie it's a lot easier to get them on
board but we get even better shots of
Vandal Savage in the past it definitely
looks like the meteorite that we saw in
the flash arrow crossover trailer has
something to do with vandal savage's
plan like either it gives him his powers
or he harnesses it is an engine for
change if it wasn't clear flash and
error on break this week when they come
back next week that's the big crossover
episode it's two hours long part one is
on the flash part two is on arrow that's
gonna set up legends of tomorrow it's
kind of like a legends of tomorrow to
our episode but even though they don't
appear in this trailer Oliver and Barry
will be on legends of tomorrow just not
every single episode like we see Laurel
in the trailer most of the big
characters from arrow in the flash will
crossover the really cool thing is that
the villains will cross over to so that
means oom and damian darhk-- I don't
know if they're gonna be working with
Vandal Savage then if you're gonna be
one of the most powerful people on the
planet you are going to bump into him at
some point in time just look at Jax's
firestorm costume though this is so
close to the comic books it's crazy when
he says he does more that means that
he's going to have extra powers that we
haven't seen firestorm use yet my first
thought is that they'll just show him
using his transmutation powers that's a
big part of the firestorm matrix in the
comics being able to modify the
molecular structure of objects because
Hawkman and Hawkgirl are so important to
vandal savage's backstory might hate
we'll follow you across time as he said
in the last trailer a lot of these
moments that we're seeing in the trailer
are from their comics are from like the
Hawkman Hawkgirl comic book stories like
Saint Rock University st. Rock the city
actually shows up during Hawkman solo
title if you look here this is actually
the new arrow cave from arrow season 4
that looks like it's in ruins this is
the far future they did say that we
would see a future version of the green
arrow that's not Oliver Queen like it's
some
in the far future Oliver dies and
another person is inspired to take up
the mantle they made it sound like
connor hawke but it would not be
Oliver's child so Connor Hawke might be
on the show but he's not gonna be all of
her son and when rip hunter yells at
them for messing with the timeline they
actually do derp a little bit and try to
change their own histories for the
better like you see the atom here this
is his wife remember how she died when
they were out together he wasn't able to
save her so that inspired him to become
the atom he's gonna try and change that
captain Cole talking to himself as a
child you get the idea butterfly effect
so part of the drama of the show is them
fixing the problems that they create for
themselves - in addition to fixing
Vandal Savage problems the really
interesting thing though is that on part
two of the big crossover episode they're
supposed to develop some sort of weapon
for dealing with Vandal Savage I have no
idea what that's gonna be but they did
say that it would involve team Flash and
team arrow working together so I'm
hoping it's like a cross between
something mystical and something
technological but everybody freaked out
get height I mean there was a game of
Thrones stuff this morning about Jon
Snow now we have legends of tomorrow
there's gonna be new Star Wars stuff
later tonight so there's a whole bunch
of videos that I'm working on I have a
new Jessica Jones new Marvel stuff new
Star Wars why you guys wait for
everything to post you can click here to
learn all about that big game of Thrones
Jon Snow teaser that HBO released and
you can click here for all my other
flash arrow videos and you can click
here for the and you can click here for
my trailer for the flash arrow crossover
that's happening next week thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight